الولايات المتحده يبدو انها تخسر معركه
التكنولوجيا مع الصين وبالتالي ستخسر
واشنطن والدول الغربيه عموما التنافس
العالمي في المجال البحثي وفق تقرير معهد
السياسه الاستراتيجيه الاستراليه الارقام
مشاهدينا كشفت ان الصين ستقود مستقبل
الابحاث التكنولوجيه المهمه في العالم بعد
ان قادت سبعه وثلاثين من اصل اربعه
واربعين بحثا في قطاعات الدفاع والفضاء
والروبوتات والطاقه والبيئه والذكاء
الاصطناعي وغيرها من العلوم المهمه افضل
عشره معاهد بحثيه في العالم موجوده في
الصين ويقودها باحثون الصينيون مما يعني
انه على المدى الطويل ستصبح الصين المحرك
الاول للتكنولوجيا في العالم وحتى في
التقنيات المستقبليه التي لم توجد بعد
اكثر من ذلك فنحو 48% من الاوراق البحثيه
عاليه التاثير بشان محركات الطائرات
المتطوره تقودها الصين ايضا حسب التقرير
والانجاز المدهش لها كان في مجال الصواريخ
فرض صوتيه في عام 2021 الامر الذي فاجا
المجتمع الامريكي والغربي لا توجد دوله
مشاهدين اخرى قريبه من الصين والولايات
المتحده في السباق البحثي لكن الهند
والمملكه المتحده
تتصدرنا تتصدران المشهد اذا عن بعد
[موسيقى]